Hallo, mein Name ist Alice und Sie haben das vielleicht
aus meiner Opernfolge gesehen und ich
lerne gerade Deutsch und die Idee
ist, dass ich das, was ich gelernt habe,
an Sie weitergeben kann, wenn Sie auch Deutsch lernen,
also möchte ich das heute tun  über die
gefürchteten Nominativ-, Akkusativ- und Dativfälle zu sprechen.
Ich denke nicht, dass das so
schwierig ist, wie die Leute es darstellen. Ich
denke, dass es einen Weg gibt, es zu verstehen
und es einfacher und einfacher
für Sie zu machen, so wie ich  Verstehen Sie die
Fälle Nominativ, Akkusativ und Dativ,
ich verstehe darunter das Subjekt, das
Objekt und das indirekte Objekt eines
Satzes, etwas, das in allen
Sprachen einschließlich der englischen Sprache existiert
, sobald Sie in der Lage sind,
das Subjekt, das Objekt und das Indirekte zu identifizieren
Objekt eines Satzes, dann werden Sie
definitiv in der Lage sein, den
Nominativ, Akkusativ und Dativ zu verstehen,
also werden wir das heute durchgehen,
also zuerst in einem Satz
, um das Subjekt identifizieren zu können, das wir haben
t  o Identifizieren Sie zuerst das Verb und
schauen wir uns diesen Satz hier an Tommy
tanzte auf dem Tisch, damit wir hier sehen können,
dass das Verb Tanz ist. Dieses Thema
ist im Grunde die Sache oder die Person
, die das Verb tut, und die Sache oder die
Person, die das tut  Das Verb hier ist Tommy,
also ist Tommy das Subjekt, okay, jetzt
denken wir über das Objekt nach, also schauen
wir uns den Satz an, der Hund fängt einen Knochen, okay, also wissen wir bereits, dass Sie
das Verb identifizieren müssen, das fangen soll, dann
wissen wir bereits, dass das Subjekt  ist der
Hund, weil es der Hund ist,
der fängt, also ist der Hund das Subjekt
, um das Objekt zu finden, müssen wir uns fragen,
was der Hund
oder wer der Hund fängt, und die Antwort
ist ein Knochen. Der Hund fängt einen Knochen
bone ist das direkte Objekt der
Empfänger des Verbs now für das direkte
Endobjekt, also ist das direkte Endobjekt
tatsächlich nicht in jedem einzelnen Satz zu finden, im
Gegensatz zum Objekt zum Thema, aber die
Art, sich an das indirekte Objekt zu erinnern, ist,
dass th  Der Empfänger des direkten Objekts
okay, das macht für Sie vielleicht keinen vollständigen
Sinn, aber schauen wir uns diesen
Satz an. Der Satz
Jeff warf einen Ball, um zu markieren, damit wir wissen
, unterstreichen wir das Verb drei, wir wissen,
dass das Subjekt Jeff ist, weil es
Jeff ist  das macht das Werfen und wir
wissen, dass der Ball das Objekt ist, weil
wir antworten können, was Jeff wirft, Jeff
wirft einen Ball, und dann ist das direkte
Objekt, wem Jeff den
Ball zuwirft, und die Antwort ist, so den
Weg zu markieren  Denken Sie immer daran, dass das indirekte
Objekt ist, indem Sie mich fragen, an wen oder
für wen. Okay, also hoffe ich, dass
Ihnen das geholfen hat, und jetzt, da wir wissen, was
das direkte Objekt und das indirekte
Objekt ist, werden Sie jetzt
etwas besser verstehen, was der Nominativ
Akkusativ ist  und Dativ Dativ
ist also daran denken, dass dieses Subjekt
dem Nominativ sehr ähnlich ist, das direkte
Objekt dem Akkusativ sehr ähnlich ist
und das zornige Endobjekt
dem Dativ sehr ähnlich ist, also hoffe ich, dass das so ist  Es ist
Ihnen klar und das wird
Ihnen helfen, Deutsch einfacher und
effizienter zu lernen